hey whats up guys its Marcus brown lahir
from mkbhd and welcome to another HD
tutorial in which i will show you guys
how to change the icons you have in your
rocketdock folder so or not your folder
but your rocket dock icons so at the top
you might see here that i do have a
number of rocket dock icons i have these
you know those shortcuts basically two
different programs and rocket dock and
object dock are both the docks that i
use on the top and on the left actually
i'm going to show you guys how to change
your object dock icons using a few
simple steps now you might have noticed
that a few of the icons on here don't
have most appealing icons for example
the camtasia studio icons usually aren't
nice looking and they usually look like
this right here so i'm going to change
you i'm going to show you guys how to
change the icon you have for whatever
image you like so first of all you're
going to have to find your image so you
know just hook up a search engine and go
ahead and search whatever you want and
make sure it's a PNG file because those
have transparent background so i'm going
to search camcorder icon PNG and i'm
going to filter it for images and you
might like a number of the icons here i
happen to like this digital camcorder
icon right here and it's convenient
because it is a 128 x 128 square what
we're going to do is right click it and
save image to desktop arm and once we
have it on our desktop here you can you
know move around to any place we want
just make sure we can always find it now
we're going to change that camcorder
that camtasia studio camcorder to what
we actually want it to be so just go
ahead and right click on the icon of
choice and scroll down to dock entry
properties click dock entry properties
and here you'll go ahead and hit that
change image button now there's there's
actually a number of bundled images that
you can choose from that actually come
with object doc but I didn't I didn't
want to use any of those so go ahead and
browse for our PNG file go to our
desktop and here we'll find that
camcorder image hopefully right there
there it is digital camcorder PNG image
just go ahead and hit open and okay and
it'll be right there so there you go
there's that object icon that's the
Camtasia recorder I'm probably going to
change the cam trees camtasia studio one
as well and if you do plan on changing
where you where you store this digital
camcorder icon make sure you rear out
this and you go ahead and reset it after
you've moved it so that is basically it
guys enjoy your new your new fully
revamped object doc and I you know I
hope it matches the theme of your
computer whatever you happen to like and
that is basically it so thanks for
watching this tutorial and I'll catch
you guys in the next video peace